I think it's time for Assyria to give me
a random number give me a random number
between wait here's two quiets give me a
random number between one and seven
series so quiet it said one Guy Debord
okay what do I play let's play the Polar
Bear opening I even know what the polar
bear opening is but I saw some Wikipedia
posts like a year or two ago I'm gonna
try and remember what I saw it's
something like this where like
eventually wipe lazy for
and assuming black doesn't challenge my
setup I should be able to play the polar
bear not sure why they call it the polar
bear maybe because it's almost extinct
no one plays this well does preferred
opening as White's black you prefer
Petrov defense well I guess this is an
opening you can add to your arsenal does
a polar bear include a four maybe it
does
my peripheral opening as white as
usually London unless I feel like
playing something else how did I do in
my treatments the first trim it wasn't
so great it scored five out of nine and
then this tournament is going better I
have four drawers in one win and from
Kazakhstan nice display a Ford I don't
really have too many ambitions about
getting the GM title I think a lot of
people don't fully understand there's a
pretty big gap between iron and GM and
to get the GM title it would take at
least a couple years of full devotion
and it's just not not something I'm
gonna heavily pursue it's just as
stressful especially playing these long
events okay so I think I've successfully
executed the polar bear which would
normally get me arrested for poaching
but here it's it's okay now I guess I
want to play Queenie one it might be
difficult to play E for because this
Bishop is annoying so maybe I'll play
like h3 g4 and then just attack on the
Kings side
can i play the English I'll take opening
recommendations so there is a book on
the polar very interesting have to do
some googling I mean getting the G on
title OD would be good for like brand
and credibility but there's all their
ways to develop my brand I mean it would
also be good for just proving to myself
I can play high level chess so we'll see
what do I do outside of chess I take
photos of chess players know probably
like outside of chess biggest passion is
photography which I'm trying to do more
of I'll be posting more to Instagram
people can follow me if you want to see
pictures my Instagram feed is like a lot
of chess players at least a few weeks
ago and then just animals 'if I've well
black one Kinect for hmm what's going on
here I wanna play Knight g5 threatening
the e6 oh this looks nice Knight g5
threatening 96 and threatening Bishop
takes d5 also preparing Queen h4 yeah I
can live with this you have a Canon 7d
nice
I shot with a Canon 7d in my early days
of college when I could rent out
equipment that was one of the cameras I
rented that good camera I recently
switched from Canon to Sony because Sony
has silent shooting ok I'm playing 93
because I want to attack d5 which he
okay obstructs a bishop so if I take
mm-hmm
ceefor could be interesting well spicy
for like black has an impressive kind of
confirmation so the way to try and
destabilize the paw information is to
attack like d5 and f5 I'm trying my best
geum-bun Feingold favorite chest
youtuber he's one of my favorite
youtubers to like back before I had a
YouTube channel I would just binge and
Feingold videos so great shout out to
Karen big fan thanks Karen
okay so now I have an outpost on d5
Black has so much space but somehow I'm
working around the paw information look
at the spawn formation this is so weird
I just have Knights in his territory
despite his pawns this is probably
thumbnail worthy I'll call this video
like executing the polar bear wait now
that's to violence playing the polar
bear
not sure like who's better here there is
one move I'm really scared that black
might play so I guess I just have to
pray that he doesn't play it even if he
does play it I don't think it's too bad
things are gonna get weird and blacks
probably gonna flag yeah each six I was
kind of scared of because this Knight
has nowhere to go like okay I could play
96 between JC 6 and then Knight c7o and
win the bishop but then that night is
kind of getting stuck I would much
rather sacrifice and keep initiative so
I could play I don't know what to play I
could take the pawn if I take the pawn
takes and then II 5 if Queenie 697
hitting the Queen and hitting the
Knights so takes takes e5 if blacks sax
back I'll win g5 in the end
[Music]
this looks very unsound I could take on
f5 take on that five take your justice
so complicated yeah my position is just
bad but the complications should be
enough for black to go wrong
yeah let's play e5 such weird pawn
structure well now my bishop is happy he
sacks okay
so g5 is hanging but c4 is hanging so
what is going on
I could play b3 Bishop g3 comes
so I'm calculating Bishop takes g5
bishop takes c4 and then just Knight f4
I think is reasonable
I'm missing my bishop and now I'll have
some attack like I have pieces around
this area of the board
u2's attacks
[Music]
also a g4 is kind of attacked so let's
play this it takes and takes I may have
just blundered but hopefully he flags
yeah I'm pretty sure I blundered
but weird things are happening what's
going on Jake steak steaks
I'm just down upon an end he was so
close to flagging wait a minute what's
going on here jack let's throw in a
check make him think and then throw in
another check wait I think I'm winning
this because I'm saving my crook and I'm
winning this rook he should look like
keenya chaydez
ah but is he promoting probably not that
was a weird finish I think I was losing
until the very end
chess by Jay nice painting other stream
I I streamed with like a deformed baby
in the background but it was a painting
of a baby people can watch the stream to
realize what I'm talking about
this probably has some underlying
meaning that I'm not aware of yeah let's
look at that game also let's look at
what exactly the polar bear opening is
because I just went off my vague memory
of Wikipedia a polar bear opening
Wikipedia oh I need to type in bear Oh
is there no Wikipedia page polar bear
opening chess huh
just gonna go to google image search
I really thought there is like some just
setup
I've been polar bear opening then just
got pictures of polar bears ah maybe
it's with the like e to fianchetto I
don't know this is probably a discussion
for later let's just take a look at the
ending or the middle game such a weird
position the computer will probably just
say how badly we both played so let's
turn it off and yeah round here like
Bishop f3 was a bad move I think because
it allowed this forcing line and then I
was losing a pawn I think Bishop takes
e2 is good
a bishop defy was very tricky because
King g7 then Black is losing King h8 on
the other hand I don't have a way to
effectively save my rook and the problem
in this position if I attack the bishop
there's d3 if I take then there's d2
okay maybe I can hold on for a draw out
but I have no winning chances the same
thing with rook f2 like I've broke up to
just d3 takes here and this is even
worse because he's just promoting so got
a little bit fortunate for that's life